foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be discussing the most
recent news regarding the other Game of
Thrones successor shows that were in
development at HBO now before any of you
lose your minds I want to make sure
everyone understands this has nothing to
do with House of the Dragon there is
another reason why you're seeing the sea
snake on my thumbnail so don't jump out
that window just yet House of the Dragon
isn't going anywhere not after all the
success it just had also make sure you
stay until the end of this video because
there's a massive new update from George
RR Martin himself now as I'm sure most
of you already know HBO has been
developing a number of different Game of
Thrones shows based on George RR
Martin's World Of A Song of Ice and Fire
after the global success of Game of
Thrones HBO started developing other
shows set in Westeros and even essos
before the original show ended over
three years ago now that they've found
even more success with House of the
Dragon I have to assume and secretly
hope HBO is working hard to get another
show off the ground well according to
this new article it seems HBO might have
shut down a few of these other successor
shows that were in the early stages of
development if you have seen all of my
update videos before then you know HBO
was working on a show about the sea
snake and his legendary nine voyages
from around the world of Ice and Fire
they were also developing a series about
nymeria but it seems this show is no
longer on their list either as of right
now the adventures of Duncan egg is the
only live-action show that's said to be
still in development now you have to
remember none of this information has
been confirmed by HBO this information
is from startling Inc who founded the
literary management and Company to which
George R Martin was signed well their
website once showed all the different
Game of Thrones successor shows that
were in development at HBO the series
about the sea snake and his nine voyages
as well as the series about nymeria was
once listed here with these other shows
but now it says the adventures of Duncan
egg is the only live-action successor
show that's still in development now
maybe the shows have found a different
home with another company however that
does seem very unlikely considering
startling Inc has been working with HBO
throughout the Run of Game of Thrones
and now House of the Dragon it wouldn't
make a lot of sense for them to move
somewhere else but at the end of the day
you never really know either as always
we will have to wait for a confirmation
from HBO but as of right now it does
seem accurate thankfully there was no
mention of the Jon Snow show in fact HBO
still hasn't made their own announcement
about it as of yet but George R Martin
and Amelia have already revealed they
were making the show with Game of
Thrones actor Kit Harington so like I
said don't worry we are still getting
House of the dragon's second season in
fact I guarantee that show isn't going
anywhere after all the success it had
and we might still see this Jon Snow
series as long as HBO doesn't announce
it's shut down then I will have to
assume they're still making it as always
I will make sure that you're up to date
with any and all information regarding
these shows as well as anything
regarding Game of Thrones House of the
dragon or a Song of Ice and Fire now let
me give you the most recent update about
the wins of winter like I said at the
beginning of this video George RR Martin
recently revealed a major new update
about his next novel In The Song of Ice
and Fire Saga during a recent interview
he finally revealed exactly how much he
has written in the Winds of Winter
desert dragons and Storm of Swords are
the two largest books in the series they
were both about 1500 manuscript pages I
think this one is going to be longer
than that by the time I finish it and I
think I'm about three quarters of the
way done maybe
um but that's not a hundred percent done
so I I have to continue to work on it as
you can see George R Martin has finally
confirmed exactly how far along he is
with the next novel this is something
millions of fans have been wondering
ever since it was delayed year after
year most fans have already given up on
the idea of ever reading the wins of
winter because a lot of them assume he
will never get it done as I'm sure most
of you already know it has been over a
decade since George R Martin released
his last installment from The Song of
Ice and Fire Saga in fact the dance
would drag Dragons released right around
the first season of Game of Thrones and
now we've just finished the first season
of House of the dragon and the Winds of
Winter still isn't here when you think
about it it's actually kind of amazing
in a negative sort of way now if you're
someone who watches all my videos then
you know I always go back and forth with
if I think we will ever see the damn
novel George RR Martin has given us so
many updates in the last decade
sometimes it's hard to know whether he's
almost done or if he's given up well
considering he's now saying it's 75 done
I do think we will eventually see the
Winds of Winter let's all hope we will
get it during the off season of House of
the dragon that would actually be
amazing because that's when we will need
it the most I would love to dive back
into the original story the way it was
meant to be written while we wait for
the follow-up of House of the dragon's
incredible first season now will we ever
see a dream of spring I don't know you
would hope that once he finishes writing
this mess that is the ones of winter
maybe a dream of spring will be much
easier I'm also assuming a lot more
characters will die in the wins of
winter as well so that will be less
adapters they will have to write for the
final novel but I don't want to get
ahead of myself either let's just see if
we will get this next one first before I
start thinking about a dream of spring
let me know what all of you think about
these new updates down below
um I do have to ask you since I have you
here last year you gave you have you've
given us some teases about the Winds of
Winter but last year you dropped the
bomb that you had a Twist that you were
contemplating but you weren't sure if
you were going to go ahead with it can
you tell us if you've decided and if
we'll know what it is when we when we
eventually read it
um
I have decided to do that yes I have
decided to do it and will you know it I
don't know
um it's fairly obvious because it's a
certainly involves a couple characters
one of whom is dead in the show but not
dead in the books so the show can't do
this she is UT because they've killed a
character that I have not killed
um but that doesn't narrow it down much
because at this point there are like 15
characters who are dead on the show who
are still live in the books yeah I get
all of this uh the stuff about being
bloody minded but David and Dan are uh
bloodier than I am listen I saw I saw
your audience are expensive no I saw
your office bathroom you have the psycho
bloody handprints did any of you want to
see those shows about the sea snake or
nymeria and how many of you think we
will actually get the wins of winter
soon I want to know what all of you
think as always I have to thank all of
you for stopping by and watching my
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon in the
next one bye
you know what I rewatched it always did
you yeah
this is me yeah I fit what did you think
um it was it definitely fell off at the
end
but it started really strong
I was like I was heartbroken when that
died he ever knew it was coming and I
was like because I I for the first time
I know
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
thank you